we are only that mark bridger has today
being found guilty of the murder of our
beautiful daughter April April be
forever in our hearts and we are so
moved by the overwhelming support we
have had from so many people from all
over the world Paul and I would like to
thank the big powers police for their
support you have given us the
investigation team the search team from
all over the UK and our family liaison
officers we'd like to find our family
and friends and the community of my own
class well without their support we did
not know how would we would have to get
how to get through the last several
months since April is so cruelly taken
from us